to the mother woman that don't have
substance believe they're like the top
prize or like Rihanna and they feel
entitled to certain behaviors
let me tell you something so let me tell
you something like
a staple of the modern woman right they
believe that they are higher than their
level right so I've always said
you see when you take your makeup off
and your lashes off and your nails off
and you'll wake off and your hair inches
out and then you go to bed that's what
you are that's your level
I feel like I always get this though
yeah hang on hang on hang on hang on
like you're higher than your level
because you put makeup on and weave in
and Nails on
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what do you mean
a lot of modern women tend to think that
because how they look after they're made
up that's their level no my dear because
the bottom line is when a man goes to
bed with you you've gone back down to
that level and that is what he's seeing
on a daily basis when you're walking
around the house that's what you're
seeing so don't act
like you're a 10 when you're uh
and at carnival and at carnival when I
was asking I went around I said rate
yourself one to ten
ten I'm a ten I'm a 10 I'm a ten bro
you're like a five you're average look
yeah but again
is it not okay to set to be confident
though no no no but it's not okay it's
not okay to lie to yourself but let's
keep it 100 you see the makeup the wick
is off it's all a must it's a must I
personally believe that when girls are
have makeup when you approach them they
have a different personalities if you're
a person when you're approaching without
makeup they tend to be more portable
more talkable more have more of a Vibe
but when you approach them when they
have makeup they're all like I'm the
[__] I'm the [__] but why are you hold
on makeup as well when actually men
makeup is fine but
women will speak they will spend two
hours on their homework do you know what
I'm saying and they will look totally
different we've all seen fishing videos
we've all seen The Tick Tock videos of
woman looking a certain way doing her
makeup
right okay so there are a lot of women
out there me Brandon uh what's your name
again bro Fury out we don't need to do
that we are beautiful right but we will
look like this all the time right
yourself do you look like now I'm just
saying the truth because a lot of women
like don't think they tell me because of
all these makeup all these fake things
but us men like I think a lot of men in
general they just don't know their worth
some some men are naturally nines what
they think they're seven because I don't
know yeah which is the same with women
as well you know that's why a lot of
even beautiful no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no okay it if I go up to
a girl and I say you're average they
take it as an insult even though most
people are average yeah yeah no I'm just
like oh I say that all the time you're
very um forward about it no maybe that's
what makes them feel like it's a bit of
an insult do you think you're average no
okay do you think you're average I think
I'm all right do you think you're
probably talking about looks or as a
whole as a whole okay so let's go on
what men judge you once so men are going
to initially judge you before on before
you even open your mouth okay right men
are gonna judge you based on what you
look like aesthetically right out of the
world out of all the beautiful girls I'm
average okay
Linda do you figure average or above
average I think I think I'm average okay
one thing yeah so the only person that
said you were above average or you're
not average was you yeah definitely I'll
tell you why but I'm beautiful can't be
the most beautiful girl in the world I
want to ask you something make yourself
from 10. okay
in what like just in invisible person I
give myself an 8.5 okay okay now okay
okay it's here that's nice but let's say
you we actually bring women that
actually 8.5 are you really gonna say
that you're 8.5 hang on yeah did you
call yourself at 8.5 yeah
I would wait wait wait I see my face
I'll show you without makeup fantastic
so what celebrity
or person in the media would you also
rate at 8.5 that's the thing I feel like
a lot of people that are in the media
they answer the question they are rich
they are come on it's a question that
requires explanation because this is a
deep question
most people in the media most people
that are celebrities they are what you
call Rich hot where they are not
actually good looking where they annoys
their money and everything so
self-defense mechanism word salad no but
I'm just saying so there's not really
many people without saying that hot my
German she's beautiful she's got natural
look so you think you are on the same
level as my Jammer I would say my Jammer
probably is a bit more because she's got
more access to it
please like it's not even listen just be
real with yourself now behold yourself
it's okay to be a fight it's okay wait
wait I didn't say all five I'm giving
you a good example one calm that
everyone calm down
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make you
accountable for the words that come out
of your mouth so you said you were an
8.5 yes and you said and I asked you
what celebrity within the media or
whatever is would you also classes at
8.5 should probably be a nine maybe okay
so give me give me someone who you think
that you're on the same level as
there's not many to be honest it's quite
hard to think you can't answer the
question because you cannot simply take
account to believe that you are not 8.5
no because if we do bring women that 8.5
around you you're gonna hide your face
I'll tell you I'll tell you why because
I'll tell you why I don't need you know
what the term delusions of grandeur no
listen listen I'll tell you something
you would be hating if you tell me I'm
not being
because I'll tell you something
something
you're not an 8.5
one at a time I'll tell you why I'm an
8.5 right and probably can do more Once
Upon richer I'll definitely Elevate now
I'll tell you one I'm a natural beauty
number one you're a great TV okay yeah
well if you're laughing you're hating
okay no no continue if we didn't meet in
this contest no one's hating on you
listen you see I know you got not girls
but majority of girls like to like
they've they cover all the lives of the
truth easy the truth because let's keep
it 100 yeah
maybe because uh tens or nines literally
approached you but you don't understand
they just want your kids you don't
really find you attractive like that
I'll tell you something every woman has
Gucci and then there's levels to this
[__] I know I'm on the level okay now on
the 8.5 level yeah okay cool yeah I'm
not even sure let me let me let me ask
you let me ask you another question
yeah true and I think I'm an 8.5 do you
think do you think women yeah generally
understand how to differentiate yeah
between attention from men that says
you're [__] sexy
opposed to I want to make you my wife
100 yes no no but I'm saying do you
think women know how to differentiate it
hang on wait wait Linda Linda go on I
don't think so why because
they they don't yeah because they a lot
of like a lot of women you know they
look for guys that are smooth as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible